[Music]
this is where it all began
the story of candy man local character
he walk around handing out candy to the
neighborhood kids
one day a couple of kids get razor
blades in their candy
police come around that's when i saw the
true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him tortured him killed him
right there a couple weeks later
more razor blades and more candy he'd
been innocent
so he's real candy man ain't he
candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
god
right here in this neighborhood the
legend started
uh-huh and the legend is
if we say his name five times while
looking in the mirror
we could summon him summon the candy man
hell no
black people don't need to be summoning
no i dare you don't say that he's like
you better not do that last one you want
to be a part of the story right no
say his name candy man
anthony anthony
anthony are you okay
the hell is going on this neighborhood
is haunted
i think i made a mistake i brought him
back caveman
isn't real he told me he has purpose for
you
tell new to the neighborhood
you should say candyman say his name
[Music]
you
[Music]